les drones intelligente des canaux en
béton des véhicules roulant de tous les
genres y compris des voitures solaires
on est de plus en plus en train de
pousser vers une voiture conventionnelle
les voitures qu'on pourrait fabriquer
l'école polytechnique reste un
laboratoire de nouvelles idées et cette
journée portes ouvertes attire toujours
les foules
il faut dire que tous les secteurs de
pointe sont en mal d'ingénieurs tout ce
qui est technologies informatiques
logiciels
on est vraiment dans une effervescence
dans ces domaines là toutes les
programmes de génie sont sont populaires
il ya du placement à 98% dans toutes les
spécialités que hong hanh en ce moment
juste les enjeux reliés aux
manufacturiers intelligent non contexte
industries 4 0 on a une convergence de
technologies
on parle de science des données
l'intelligence artificielle la robotique
les chaînes d'approvisionnement
ça va être un enjeu la cybersécurité
donc on a besoin de former les gens pour
qu'ils puissent répondre à ces enjeux de
l'eau de façon adéquate sur des huit
mille six cents étudiants de
polytechnique 30 % viennent maintenant
de l'étranger principalement de france
et de belgique
ils y trouvent leur compte maintenant je
suis ici la qualité de vie m e phung
rester et je compte rester par la suite
au canada aspect très important c'est
l'aspect entrepreneuriale on ne gère
comme une mini entreprise et le fait de
travailler là dedans nous donne vraiment
des compétences qui sont très favorables
pour
l'âme le monde professionnel surtout en
tant qu'ingénieur ce père s'y prend à
l'avancé pour déclencher une vocation
active chez son jeune fils de voir dans
son futur
c'est je crois que ça se prépare jeunes
puis je pense qu'en ce moment leur
double c'est bien construire les choses
lise machine et qui après les réagissent
et michel merlet radio canada montréal